remercié son altesse
le sultan de brunei pour l'organisation
de la rencontre d'aujourd'hui
le sommet d'asie orientale et une canne
ont une occasion de
d'aborder tous les problèmes qui se
posent aujourd'hui
et développer des mesures pour soutenir
la stabilité et renforcer notre
coopération sur tous les plans cette
région qui est commune à tous est une
des plus dynamiques temps pour les
affaires que pour les milieux politiques
pour
nos pays et en même temps cette région
est confrontée à de sécurité importantes
sur le plan de la sécurité du
développement social de l'économie et
ces dernières années à ces défis s'est
ajoutée la question du recours aux
navires us et c'est bien pour cela que
notre sommet se concentre sur la
question de la lutte contre la pandémie
et la mise en oeuvre des initiatives qui
avaient été prises notamment à
l'initiative de la fédération de russie
en matière de coordination des actions
contre la diffusion de la pandémie
donc je propose que les pays intéressés
puissent procéder à cet échange
d'expériences
nous pourrions aussi élargir le
programme de formation des spécialistes
des épidémiologistes
dents au sein du centre d'études
et en décembre un certain nombre de
cours de formation professionnelle
dédiée vont être mises en place et nous
attendons des représentants des pays
concernés j'ajoute que
la russie apporte une contribution très
importante sur l'accès aux vaccins sont
dit vicent d'immigration pour les
citoyens de tous les pays nous nous
prononçons pour le développement d'une
procédure de reconnaissance des
certificats de vaccination mutuelle sans
laquelle on ne peut pas assurer une
libre circulation des citoyens
le produit russe ce que tva était après
approuvé par 70 pays est livré dans plus
de 50 pays et je suis convaincu que les
pays de la région
de la région asie orientale peuvent être
intéressés et notamment sur la mise en
place et l'utilisation de de réactifs
pour les centres de production de ce
vaccin
les différentes modalités de lutte
contre la pandémie sont importantes et
notamment nous nous concentrons sur le
bien-être de la population et nous
approuvons tout à fait la déclaration
proposée par le souverain de brunei et
sous l'égide de ce sommet nous pouvons
mettre en place des mécanismes communs
et de lutte contre la pandémie et
notamment en facilitant un échange au
niveau des experts chers collègues il
nous paraît très important que les états
de notre région
continue à renforcer leurs liens
économiques et commerciaux d'autant plus
que cette activité ne cesse que de se
renforcer et la russie par exemple à
voix vu augmenter
son baby sous pb de 23% par rapport à
l'année 2020
et pour les huit premiers mois de
l'année en cours
nos échanges avec les pays de la région
ont augmenté de plus de 30% jusqu'à 162
milliards de dollars et donc ces
investissements qui ont été faits dans
l'économie ont représenté 18 milliards
de dollars et en cinq ans cela
représente une augmentation par deux
et cet assainissement de l'économie est
important et nous avons un certain
nombre de mesures à prendre pour
renforcer les secteurs clés de nos
économies et
coordonner nos efforts une attention
particulière doit être à notre avis
accordée au tourisme dans la mesure où
c'est un des secteurs qui a le plus
souffert de la pandémie
et pour la plupart pour un grand nombre
de pays de notre région ces jupes
participants à ce sommet le tourisme est
justement un secteur important avec plus
de 10% des recettes nationales et
la russie a proposé justement de faire
une déclaration en ce sens c'est à dire
de soutien au secteur touristique et
nous pourrions organiser une rencontre
spécialisé en 2022 pour les responsables
des ministères et services concernés et
al à l'avenir de pourrions établir ce
genre de contact de façon régulière
pour que cela puisse servir de moteur
pour les autres secteurs notamment le
secteur industriel secteur financier et
je pense que nous pourrions proposer aux
dirigeants pour le sommet de l'année
prochaine un certain nombre de
d'orientation en ce sens
nous soutenons également là le souhait
d'adopter à la fin de ce sommet une
déclaration sur le développement durable
est également sur la lutte contre les
changements climatiques
pour l'organisation de rencontres
cherchant travaillant sur la réduction
des rejets dans l'air et bien entendu
nous sommes intéressés à la coopération
qui peut être mise en place sur la
thématique de la numérisation puisque
les technologies de l'information sont
très importantes joue un rôle très
important dans le renforcement de la
coopération et de l'interférence entre
nos services
nous espérons que il y aura ici un
retour important
notamment au niveau de l'asian et des
régions aussi des villes des régions aux
nôtres ray notre capitale moscou fait
partie des villes les plus intelligentes
du monde et nous pouvons donc proposé un
certain nombre de solutions sur les
problèmes qui se posent aujourd'hui en
matière de santé publique de stabilité
sociale
et de soutien aussi à la sécurité à la
stabilité régionale ce cette thématique
est d'autant plus d'actualité que
deux on voit les problèmes augmentent et
donc il y a des nouvelles situations de
conflits qui apparaissent ici sur notre
continent dans notre région il y à la
question qui se pose de du déploiement
de missiles de portée intermédiaire et
sur cet espace gigantesque de notre
région
cela pourrait déboucher sur une nouvelle
course aux abonnements et face à cette
évolution rapide la russie a proposé un
moratoire de façon unilatérale pour
limiter
ces la double déploiement de ces
armements et propose de discuter là
dessus à tous les pays intéressant cette
proposition russe est toujours
d'actualité et son actualité ne fait
même que qu'augmenter la russie se
prononcent régulièrement pour la
un accord sur des bases l'égalité des
droits
dans le respect du droit international
et le respect de la souveraineté et la
prise en compte des intérêts nationaux
et ce n'est qu'ainsi que nous pouvons
résister et réagir aux menaces qui ne
font qu'augmenter
et c'est notre responsabilité vis-à-vis
de la communauté internationale
cela devrait favoriser le bien-être de
la population et le développement
durable la russie est toujours prête à
apporter sa contribution dans un tel
travail de coopération je vous remercie
pour votre attention